We want to caution, however, that although genetic factors play an important
role in the development of schizophrenia, just having a genetic predisposition
does not mean that somebody is going to develop the disorder. However, research
studies have shown that children who are exposed to abuse and neglect early in
life, are more likely to develop schizophrenia later in life. And that brings
us to a discussion that we had in lesson three on epigenetics, that is, a
person can have a genetic predisposition and go throughout their lives without
developing the disorder. Or they can have that genetic predisposition, be
exposed to an environmental event, and then develop the disorder. Now we've
talked before that drugs can serve as epigenetic agents, and we see here that
abuse and neglect can also serve as epigenetic agents which are responsible for
the onset of schizophrenia.